and finally new rule now that violent
crime
is at a 40-year low someone has to
explain why your local police department
has gone from this
to this
has anybody here tonight ever heard of
doraville georgia me neither
but it's a town of 8 000 people and they
have their own tank
so does nixon missouri and justice
illinois
what these small towns and hundreds just
like them have in common
besides a refreshing lack of hipsters
is that they and big cities too have
been gifted by the pentagon with
tons of government surplus war equipment
fresh from our glorious victories in
iraq and afghanistan
now i understand it's a dangerous world
out there and threats have changed
when i was a kid there was no such thing
as shia labeouf
but we don't need to fill our streets
with any more horrifying death machines
when we've already got gm
the military should dispose of these
things the way they always did in the
past
by selling them to arnold schwarzenegger
because cops are only human and we all
know what it's like when you get a new
toy
you want to use it i bought a glue gun
once and by the end of the weekend my
dog's face was stuck to the toilet grill
but in west springfield massachusetts
the police department's new toy
is two grenade launchers why
in case boko haram takes connecticut
it's hard enough keeping the george
zimmerman's out of the police academy
without having bazookas in the brochure
once you start dressing and equipping
people like an occupying army
they start acting like one every day
there's another story in the paper about
cops beating innocent people the video
that's been making the rounds out here
lately is a patrolman
punching the lights out of a deranged
homeless grandmother
even worse that's their training video
i mean this guy has been demoted to desk
duty while officials conduct a review
but
what's to review he's punching an old
lady in the face
which is not to say most cops act like
this they don't
and if you're a police officer who
happens to pull me over sometime
in the near future i'm especially not
talking about you
oh no you're fine and handsome
and i rarely say that to a man thank you
for your service
and let's just both agree that the
strong smell coming from my car
is a skunk i rescued on the road and
brought into the vet a few days ago
you know i have no illusions what life
would be like without the police it
would be that movie the purge every
night
but unfortunately it's not just the
equipment the cops are borrowing from
the army
it's also this philosophy of
overwhelming force
you know we used to send swat teams only
for hostage or
active shooter scenarios it happened a
few thousand times a year
now it happens a thousand times a week
forced
no knock entries into private homes and
now for almost any reason at all like
serving warrants
breaking up poker games arresting
low-level
pot dealers come on it's a guy who sells
weed you don't need to shoot his dog and
crash through his window
just grab him when he comes out for the
ice cream truck
you know police we want to be on your
side
but the words on your car protect and
serve
refer to us not you
and
in the 90s conservatives used to warn
about jack-booted government thugs
coming to take away our freedoms but
where are those conservatives today when
we need them
this is the massive expansion of
government power that you
numbskulls in the tea party should be
freaking out about
you're always screaming
you're always screaming about the loss
of liberty and how tyranny is coming
yeah it's coming right through the door
with a battering ram
no warrant and a stun grenade or to put
it in a way you can understand
i'm scared of the cops and i'm white
that's our show i'll be at heinz hall in
pittsburgh on july 26th rm kirby center
in wilkes-barre pennsylvania
27th and at the arthurian theater in
sioux city august 15th i want to thank
jamie weinstein nate silver jane harmon
george mckay
and the reverend dr william barber join
us on overtime and thank you folks